we spend Millions every month producing
content so that we can acquire customers
get their data and sell them goods and
services all over the world this is very
expensive so how do I reduce my
production costs AI artificial
intelligence let's take Switzerland
French and German these are two of the
biggest languages there so if I'm going
to produce content I have to produce it
in two different languages but not if I
have ai I can have one talking head
speak two different languages using AI
that's exactly what I intend to do
number one market on Earth United States
number two China guess who's number
three this place the Falcon economy they
are doing some of the most advanced work
in actually monetizing Ai and they have
a very attractive tax rate 9% so you can
produce content here generate it from
here bring Revenue in here at a 9% tax
rate I find that very attractive don't
you